- Welcome to Hickory,
North Carolina.
Let me show you around.
Got my leg vise.
Got it for Christmas
from my father a few years ago.
Recently I transitioned
to propane.
This is a triple burner,
like what we have on the show.
It's the exact same forge,
brick-lined and everything.
We've got
a hundred-pound anvil here.
It's nothing fancy,
but it gets the job done,
and what's really cool
about it,
it was in 1880
that it was made.
Plenty of history behind it
as well.
This is my triangle of death,
just a continuous
circle of life,
always forge, anvil, vise,
forge, anvil, vise.
Stay down.
You know I'm gonna try
a little dancing.
Might get hurt.
- Hi, my name's Chris Price.
Welcome to my shop.
♪ ♪
I still work out of
a little garden shed,
here in Alexandria, Virginia.
I've got
a small homebuilt forge.
I have a really nice hydraulic
forging press.
♪ ♪
Simple anvil.
Simple little grinder.
That's how I do all my work.
♪ ♪
- My name is
David Sowards-Emmerd,
and we're here in
Bend, Oregon,
and I'm gonna show you
my home forge.
This is where most of
the forging takes place.
I have my bigger
Damascus forge here
and a couple little forges
that I'll move around.
So this is
a pretty simple forge.
I just--it's configurable.
So it's just a various mix
of fire bricks.
So I use hard fire brick
for the base
and the first layer inside,
and that also gets hot
and holds the heat.
And then soft insulating fire
bricks for the rest of it,
'cause they're just
not structurally sound.
Anvil's here.
Big post vise.
Brass wedge block.
And that's pretty much
where most things happen.
- I'm Rae Lynn Vander Weide,
and we are at my home forge
in Turlock, California.
I am a little bit limited
on what I have,
since majority of my tools
are all farrier tools.
So we've got my anvil,
which goes with me
pretty much everywhere.
This is my forge.
I absolutely love it.
It's a little
horse-shoeing one.
I mean, it's
not anything crazy,
but it gets the job done.
Stole the grinder from my dad.
I also stole this from my dad.
He'll get 'em back
eventually maybe.
And then I have
my welding set-up.
It's a cute little one.
He's dinky, but he's powerful.
♪ ♪
- I'm Matt Berry.
Welcome to my shop in
Middlefield, Connecticut.
The pros of having my forge
right in my backyard
are that I have
a 90-foot commute to work.
I can come home for lunch.
You know, it's great.
The cons are that my boss is
kind of a jerk and he makes me
work all the time, even
in the middle of the night.
It's a personal problem I have
to deal with.